now we're all familiar with strategies
for a successful job interview make eye
contact have a firm handshake and so on
but if you're applying for a position in
china it might be a computer you have to
impress that says chinese companies
increasingly use artificial intelligence
to help them vet potential new hires
twenty-year-old hua angie is heading
towards the future with her job
interview
on the other end it's not a who but a
what an artificial intelligence spot
that will decide if she's the right fit
show us that you know how to work in a
team and give a specific example
for two months i worked with six people
in three different universities
the company behind the software most
seeker explains how it works much like
in human interactions the candidates
voices and facial expressions are
crucial
we are analyzing the sound the richness
of the context and also the accuracy of
your expression so overall we will give
a
score for the
for the interview
technology is a godsend for companies
like mars in china it receives up to 50
000 job applications for just a few
hundred open positions
without ai we would have to mobilize
hundreds of colleagues for over a month
now it only takes two weeks to recruit
and she is also converted she's more
relaxed thanks to her robot interviewer
is a correspondent from taipei she joins
us now wendy why are chinese companies
turning to ai interviewers
so first of all we want to uh
notice that it's not just chinese
companies in china but also
international companies in china they
are all using especially these big
companies in china they are using the ai
interview techniques to uh recruit
especially recent graduates over the
past two to three years
and uh there's one thing i want to point
out is that um there are over nine
million uh recent college and uh
university graduates this year and the
next year their the number will be
increased uh to over 10 million
graduates so we can clearly see that
this is why these big companies they
want to use them they're trying to find
a more efficient way to recruit good
quality qualified candidates in a
really short time and with these
technologies they can um screen the huge
amount of people um like uh the package
said uh like from one month to two weeks
and we are seeing chinese companies like
uh in consumer goods sectors
real estate sectors uh or internet
sectors they are using the technology so
the idea is that it makes the
recruitment process go faster but are ai
interviewers really better than human
beings at judging whether an applicant
fits a role or a company or are they in
some ways even more discriminatory
so
for companies right now we've seen most
companies that are using the technology
in the early phase of the interview
process so these candidates will have to
record their video answers and then the
ei system will analyze their facial
recognition facial expression language
intonation and specifically the content
of their answers some say that it's
us
is
actually helping these companies to
spend
time more efficiently efficiently on the
qualified candidate and would have the
real people to answer these qualified
small amount of qualified candidates but
some also say that it is more difficult
or it's difficult for a candidate
the employers to really know
if the aggregates are accurate when it
comes to hiring decisions
okay so we have yet to see how accurate
the algorithms really are perhaps humans
might be in the mix for much longer when
it comes to recruitment but what kind of
impact has using ai to recruit personnel
had on the labor market in china say
we actually still have to wait and see
the consequences because it's just incre
started to increase um over the past two
to three years but um one thing that is
interesting that we can see there's a
phenomenon in china um there are some
so-called hr experts for experts with hr
backgrounds they are starting to train
uh job applicants for these candidates
on how to successfully um
pass the video interviews so
um they will collect question lists for
this candidate to practice
and also for those 10 uh for those
companies we also want to
see
they might have to think that how much
they want to rely on ai to make this
decision
thank you very much wenili in taipei
there for us
thank you